nam asks how did you deal with working  in a family business nam very carefully  family businesses are difficult I'm in  my second one my dad my brother I look  forward to my one with my kids one day  Misha and Xander if you want to be an  entrepreneur call me um you know I I  think the real answer is Nam the reason  I've had two successful family  businesses is very simply and kudos to  my dad and kudos to my mom and kudos to  just a lot of fortune things that  allowed my dad and I and now my brother  and I to allow our love to trump our our  pride our competitiveness our business  POVs somehow in our specific situation  probably predicated with a lot of hard  work specifically for my mom more than  you would think and my dad and then the  incredible natural DNA that they gifted  me we have created a situation where  we've allowed at the end of the day for  us not to lose focus on the fact that we  love each other more than we care about  getting our way